bonjour c'est clara luciani pour brut je
pense que le premier moment qui a
vraiment changé ma vie c'est la première
fois que je monte sur scène j'avais 19
ans et c'était en angleterre et c'est le
groupe la femme qui me donnait la
première fois la chance de faire un
concert et tout à coup j'ai su que
c'était ce que je voulais être
ouais j'ai vraiment senti que j'étais au
bon endroit que c'était que c'est
vraiment ce qu'il fallait que je fasse
de ma vie a toujours été un rêve de
faire de la musique comme pour rêver
parfois de deux volets montciel quoi
c'était ce genre de rêve et jamais je
n'aurais pensé pouvoir le réaliser le
concrétiser le dernier moment très
important de ma vie c'est mon premier
concert à l'olympia en avril c'était ma
soeur qui faisait la première partie
donc on avait de nos deux noms sur
l'olympia à chaque fois que j'allais
faire une première martial je lisais a
peut-être qu'un jour ça fait un moment
en grand en lettres rouges j'étais hyper
ému je voudrais même pas à ma mère qui
était là parce qu il était 11 heures du
matin ils sont il était arrivé je crois
à 10 heures pour voir les mecs installé
lettres rouges et il m'envoyait des
photos et je me suis un moment où ils
battront heures et je sors du taxi et
mes parents qui sont là et il y avait
déjà des fans qui est arrivé aussi
j'étais trop émue au la wii est
maintenant important c'est victoria
music je dois même 20 euros à un pote
parce que je lui ai dit mais c'est sûr
que ces thérapies taxi qui va gagner
je crois que j'ai battu les records de
de xian j'ai passé la soirée à chalais
mais c'étaient des larmes de bonheur et
c'est précieux je le sais ça n'arrive
pas tous les jours de pleurer de joie
comme ça avant de recevoir un prix
révélation scène ça avait vraiment
beaucoup d'écho pour moi parce que je
dis toujours que je me suis révélé sur
scène justement mais j'avais les mêmes à
moi même enfin je j'ai réussi à faire
des choses donc je me sentais pas
capable du tout façon dont je me serais
jamais imaginé capable et du coup tout à
coup d'être approuvé par le milieu
professionnel
ça m'a aidé un petit peu à me sentir
plus légitime sur scène je manquais je
suis manqué de de confiance en moi
beaucoup j'ai vu mon ancienne interview
que tu avais été victime de harcèlement
scolaire notamment parce que tu étais
grande très jeune
est ce qu'à ce moment là tu as
l'impression de le prendre une revanche
sur tous ces gens qui t'ont fait du mal
mais c'est je pense que c'est
c'est peut-être pas point que je fais
cette carrera là aujourd'hui
peut-être que c'est justement une une
histoire de revanche en général quand on
a quand on s'est senti vraiment
extrêmement mal traités et mal aimé
peut-être qu'on fait que ça après de
rechercher l'approbation des autres et
est même meilleur leur amour je crois
que c'est ce qu'on sait ce qui m'a
poussé à monter sur scène je crois que
c'est une trés comme ça un des marins
important c'est le moment j'ai reçu le
disque d'or sas des chiffres c'est moins
concret pour moi que de voir les gens
chanter les chansons ou de montendre à
la radio mais c'est beau en fait de
réaliser ça dehors de réaliser qu'on
fait plus de la musique juste dans sa
chambre pour soi mais qu'en fait il ya
vraiment des gens qui qu'il écoute qui
se reconnaissent dans ses chansons la
tentative au lard des disques d'or tu as
eu une pensée pour ce métier mais je
pense souvent à ce mec qui m'a largué je
me dis que en fait j'y pense et je hais
je transpose la situation sur d'autres
moments de ma vie en me disant parfois
il t'arrive entre tous pourris qui te
fout le cafard pendant des jours et des
semaines et sur le kouter l'impression
que c'est la fin des haricots
oui j'ai vu thi la fin des haricots et
et en fin de compte quand quelques
années plus tard tu tu regarde
rétrospectivement tu te rends compte que
rien n'est arrivé par hasard et que ce
truc un peu de mère va déclencher des
choses merveilleuses instruments et par
important c'était la rencontre avec
françoise hardy parce que c'est
indescriptible en fait la sensation que
ça procure de rencontrer son idole j'ai
même été très surprise de voir à quel
point il était naturel quelqu'un qui
parle sans filtre et quand elle a un
coup de coeur
je crois qu'elle est très honnête et
qu'elle est et qu'elle est que c'est
quelqu'un qui extrêmement bienveillant
et du coup elle a eu comme ça ce rôle de
bonnes fées envers moi et qu'elle a
décidé un peu devant d'en parler autour
d'elle et de faire circuler l'album un
moment où finalement il n'y avait pas
beaucoup de gens qui y croyaient déjà
quoi donc c'était une aide précieuse